Since then nuclear deal, Iran has been debating
how much it should allow the rest of the world
in, how much investment is going to be permitted
for foreign companies to have in major concerns
like oil and manufacturing.
This has been a central debate between the
moderates and reformists, as well as the more
conservative hardliners.
Moderates like President Rouhani want to allow,
say for example, 10, 15, 20% foreign investment
into a major Iranian concern.
Whereas those among the conservatives and
the more extreme hardliners really don't want
any foreign investment at all.
This of course has a huge historical precedence
because of the role that Britain and other
colonial powers played 100 years ago in controlling
Iran's oil industry.
There's a lot of deep wounds still about that
issue, and I think this is going to be a real
challenge for the Iranian leadership to figure
out what way forward, how do we become rich
again and how much do we want to let the rest
of the world dictate terms of how we will
function economically.